I was gonna shave because I I figure if
I did it might have been even more
difficult to distinguish us from one
another
this is like the Spider-Man meme in the
flesh okay yeah so first of all
apologize for calling you corny bro my
bad for calling you what I called you I
think you called me a Bam Bam Bigelow
anorexic and I jerk off rappers for a
living I understand manually stimulate
them manually masturbate yeah nice yeah
only a few only a few man yeah because
like honestly I had to get you it was
light-hearted and no and I saw I saw
your comment and you were and I saw you
give me love at the end of the interview
thing yeah yeah like I legit was rocking
with you that's why I kind of hurt my
heart you know what I call it because I
haven't I'd only saw a couple of things
and I think I just hated the rap part of
your guys's little yeah yeah yeah
it was just it just wasn't great to me
and the red part of our trajectory over
there yeah yeah so how are you doing
obviously it's been about three weeks
now since everything happened here well
it's it's been great wound up securing a
caffeine deal that's all that's going
going up right now I've been doing my
own pod going up right now no I saw you
were doing kind of like
um more like a mentally like a like a
podcast that's more geared towards
because you're obviously how long have
you been sober over three years well
congrats thank you um so the podcast
that you've been doing is it more like
mental health directed so there's like
it's like there's different content that
I'm doing over there one of the podcasts
with uh my boy Kyle is called rooning
hour and that is geared towards mental
health because we're both sober right um
then I have one called lush world where
I'm doing interviews kind of similar but
you got going on and then I'm doing
streams as well so so the stream stuff's
on caffeine yeah yeah well the rats on
that yeah it seemed like you landed on
your feet pretty well man yep shout out
to my boy EK and the A.D also was a
little bit instrumental in helping me
leverage that situation so right I think
like uh for anybody who doesn't know man
I I grew up around everybody in my
family's attics everybody from my dad to
my uncle to my cousins
every single like big male member of my
family was some sort of addict crack
heroin I mean whatever you want to call
it right
um do you remember like uh because I
always I you know the one thing about
being somebody who loves somebody who's
an addict is the most frustrating part
is trying to get them to get clean
before they're ready to get clean it's
almost like you gotta kind of just let
them fall on their face or hit rock
bottom what was your Rock Bottom see
it's weird because my
hitting bottom is essential to getting
sober but for me there is a series of
different bottoms and I would think that
I hit bottom and then and then boom I go
down through the floorboards and then
I'm in the cellar and then boom I go
through the seller and next thing I know
I'm starting to smell sulfur and I'm
approaching the seventh layer of hell
and um yeah what was that what was the
seventh layer of Hail Rock Bottom are
you sucking dick I never suck no
[__] dick
[__] hell no he was like and then I
realized when I was on my knees about to
blow this trucker for an eight ball of
cocaine no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no not just you know pitiful
incomprehensible demoralization
um just lying like being estranged with
my family yeah my friends
um you know I'm I've experienced
anything you pretty much could besides
sucking dick um you know I've been been
shot at been stabbed been incarcerated
overdosed to crypto times
um had hits on my life so you know yeah
I got one cousin of mine who in and out
of jail his whole life has overdosed
over and over he's been stabbed he's
been shot
I mean this dude it's it's crazy and
it's like then my Uncle Scott shout out
to my Uncle Scott who just got out of
prison for the [__] 98th time he just
messaged me on Facebook I could shout
out Uncle Scott man welcome home Scott
come on he's like I promise you this is
my last time Kevin I hope everything's
all right like bruh
when I was a kid this dude used to come
to my house because he was tweaking so
[__] hard running around with the
Hell's Angels this [__] would be
sitting at my sink picking his [__]
face thinking there was bugs in his
[__] He's tweaking yeah
yeah so I used to go into the bathroom
be [__] blood everywhere then my
other uncle and Aunt
we used to go to their house to play
with my cousins and all the [__]
spoons were burnt yeah it's a [__] up
life man yeah yeah that attic life is
serious and for you like because there's
a few different ways obviously there's
like did you go through AAA or n a
rather well yeah I'm in a 12-step
program but I did go to treatment as
well and um
what when I agreed to go to treatment I
had pretty much gotten to the point
where I felt like I had no more moves
the bust I had already exhausted all my
resources right you know anybody that
was foolish enough to still be close to
me my fiance at the time any of my
friends they were like not [__] with
me and it was either that or pretty much
die I had no other options and I've been
in a lot of treatment centers over the
years the first time I was 16 you know I
went to juvie got arrested for the first
time at 13. um
I the spot that I went to was for
chronic relapsers basically it's like if
you don't get sober here it's a wrap for
you this is the last stop on the train
all I'm aware and I um I thought that I
qualified as a chronic relapser but then
I realized I've never actually relapsed
because you never really clean clean I
never made an Earnest attempt at
sobriety in my life so yeah